[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et merci d'être venu un coup de poignard
tous tes amis sont là arnaud ses jambes
ses fantasmes et alors on entend chanter
la l'instant j'ai pleuré
non j'ai pleuré non je me disais quelle
élégance
quelle présence sur la scène et je
n'hésite pas à le dire tu as du génie
écoute ses fans c'est moi qui te
remercie c'est une émission tellement
formidable pour moi c'est formidable de
participer à une telle émission
ce décor cette mise en scène vraiment
quand tu veux quand tu veux je reviens
suis très bien vous savez que grâce à
notre émission coup de poignard nous
allons pouvoir savoir exactement ce
qu'il pense et nous entendons notre
document tu parles que j'ai pleuré c'est
de rire que j'ai pleuré enlevé ensuite
j'ai hâte que me les mines mais nul
il est vulgaire sapé comme l'as de pique
des textes débile sache bien j'espère
que ça va pas durer
c'est incroyable va se casser la gueule
ruisseau ce tout ce qui mérite tard et
lamentable comme émission il en ferait
qu'une parents ça c'est encore trop
enfin bravo c'est nous qui paye bravo
ils sont nuls ces mauvais je peux parler
sac et c'est tous des pousses mégots ces
mecs tout de suite la question du
psychiatre fou renault pourquoi t'es
moteur vous leur crâne et un baby gaga
est bien c'est un sans-faute chrono
merci beaucoup d'être venu
à coups de poignard et je te dis à
bientôt et sans rancune
[Musique]
en 16 cents et quelques en angleterre il
eu une période trouble dont on ne sait
pas grand chose
le roi jean régnier pour l'appeler sans
terre d'art il habitait chez les autres
deux personnages seulement sont dignes
d'intérêt
le shérif de nottingham un militaire
ambitieux mais cruel et son ennemi
acharné
robin des bois un justicier implacable
qui parlait aux oiseaux et aux arbres de
la forêt de sherwood rogen et chèvres je
parle aux oiseaux atteints je te
préparer un petit civet de chevreuil à
la sauce ciboulette et au vinaigre de
bordeaux zai tu meures dire des
nouvelles et on a cambriolé le salon pop
ans rené boismenu le bouquet ça
j'entends déjà ricaner les imbéciles et
ils ont piqué la vaisselle les salons et
l'argenterie et les vidéos non large
entre les rideaux je les ai données
attention série il est avec le mot et de
soudards quoi ses soudards de plus que
de rapidement nous et juge cette can âge
si la faune de go foutez vous au garde à
vous vendre le petit [ __ ] joumaa
trail aux jolies petites chèvres avec un
petit rideau sur le dos mais non ça
c'est mon mari qui lui a donné
mais elle est très sexy toute cette
petite chèvre là surtout avec son petit
rideau sur le dos ça me rappelle mes
vacances en algérie
allez les gars et quand on lit d'eau et
puis on l'achève
blé à le rejoindre avec deux noms bien
tu n'auras plus besoin méchaal ait
masqué bas on nous pas trop tard pour
pitié masking pitié pitié as tu eu de la
pitié toi je t'ai vu l'inversé le lait
de cette pauvre vieille sa richesse
j'ai pensé tu dans ce geste immonde je
n'ai pas fait exprès mais ce qui est il
ment le bougre à l'autre maintenant
où est il passé et toi l'homme
peux tu me dire ou es passé c'est
spadassins oui ils sont partis avec le
chinois il est mort c'est agaçant et
pour la femme par où est il passé
il est parti seul labo les petits
chemins d'isolement la première bon j'ai
compris je me démerder tout seul mais
bon campagne du kram
adieu le temps presse
je suis dans le chevalier masqué et
j'habite rue des fossés mondiale
on m'appelle le justicier des essuie le
fléau des brigades
retour ne m'a pas jean paul chaumont
policiers j'ai ramassé marié je coule
danger parlez nous en voyant les baies
de lavandières
à
agneau l'ardèche ensemble montre là
[Musique]
non
je suis
chevalier masqué chapiteau rue
- semanya jeu machabée manière était mou
chez la femme même si l'enfant
en parlant
[Musique]
oui
dessous ils bradent pour
l'atmosphère
c'est ici
philippe et
son
faux
attendez je n'ai pas si nos
c'est un fou bon j'arrête même
ça a cliqué des pots des miches à la
villette à paris j'ai fait vibrer toute
la pâte au thème de l'humour et loi vous
raconte des blagues à bout mais on vient
de parler à l'oreille de maciste
mesdames et messieurs le moment est
solennel
il va faire une déclaration j'ai la
gorge sèche envoyer la bouteille voici
une page de publicité
et classe les pit
problème d'homme w c'est un acte
ammoniac et donne raison
l'étoile est devant
toilettes
et bien voici maintenant le moment tant
attendu des questions spontanées
les listes je ne crois en rien pas
mais je respecte les opinions des eaux
[Applaudissements]
les grands crus et fort les sportifs
mais il paraît aussi que tu es très bête
est ce vrai classe
je suis très content des déchets plus
chez mu et à canon je t'emmerde les
grands surfaces lisses cfo d'écraser le
petit commerçant pas répondu à la
question tactique
[Applaudissements]
merci pensez vous que nous verrons
bientôt le mariage des prêtres en france
non hélas et bien maintenant macheist se
lève et c'est le moment solennel de son
deuxième travail qui va accomplir devant
le public français en lui tend le pain
parisien symbole vivant de la france
j'ai le souffle coupé
j'ai soif de rats mesdames et messieurs
loulou est d'ailleurs les images parlent
d'elles mêmes
j'adore dit et fait grincer jupe outre
les amish
une petite fille vient de vendre les
cordons de la politique maintenant pour
ouvrir la machine à un merveilleux
bouquet ample et je suis très émue
qu'elle ce bouquet symbolise le coeur de
notre merveilleux pays mesdames et
messieurs
j'adore les fleurs de france car ce sont
les plus saines
ce custom rom accord
je remercie le plant
sanaa ap
chalonnaise
les établissements bois mais ce que
redoutaient les estrades les
établissements de trouillards pour la
décoration est une peur sur le saint
gratien que nous remercions également
merci aussi à jean pierre pour les clous
voltalis poppy caveau pour le buffet il
vient cette magnifique cérémonie touche
mon point à ses frères j'ai même eu le
temps d'aller fait un petit tour buffet
mesdames et messieurs je me suis dit
également infiltré s'était elle montré
antenne mesdames et messieurs je vous
dirai quand même un gros hic est
maintenant rendez vous tous à la buvette
j'appelle ma gamelle
rassurez-vous il reviendra bientôt
morcellement sur vos séquences de la
tour de mare cible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le groupe juillet 43
romel le renard du désert a lancé une
contre offensive d'une très grande
ampleur
les armées alliées sont dispersés par le
déluge de fer et de feu
seul rescapé trois zones déterminées
vont tenter de l'encercler parquet
requiert aucun taxi n'ayant voulu les
déposer à tobrouk
c'est à pied qu'il vont franchir les
deux mille kilomètres de désert ce qu'il
s'en fait aucune bête au monde ne
l'aurait fait ou alors elle aurait pris
très cher
et n'oublions pas que nous sommes à la
télévision voici donc la cie pour
tobrouk avec par ordre d'arrivée à la
cantine dans le rôle de marcel laura
charles aznavour le soldat anglais sir
rupert vérité vers le soldat allemand
hans werner müller
les soldats français emile boulot et
roger moulu pour des raisons d'économie
le rôle du chien sera tenu par un très
mauvais comédiens dont nous tairons le
nom
allez moi j'aimais l'on reparlé adéquat
jeu pourra se reposer la soufflette du
ne vous laissez moi la lega allait bien
comme jour tarder
on sait où et dans la journée allez on y
va non je suis prêt d'entre eux kong
non non non tu sais le mandala droit
c'est tout je vais t'en connais beaucoup
de maîtres qui se blesse on ouvre une
boîte de conserve des coups mais
maladroit et en plus tu nous retarde
alors maintenant on avant voilà je suis
con je vous mets ici tous les deux
depuis le début je le sais qu'on maïs et
raciaux ou plus à même les caractères
non mais vraiment alors tu la boucles à
mende ont ils intérêt revêtent pas les
dingues
on va se faire repérer ils sont freinés
risotto score terre qu'ils ont entendu 6
à 6 h or on assiste à une mirage
la fièvre de la musique et cette musique
ils me rappellent mes vacances en
bavière c'est un mirage wali orages qui
causent allemand moi j'y crois pas
beaucoup hein on est attaqué par lille
et non non non non regardez c'est la
sicile à 6 et mon chien il a fait 28
mille kilomètres pour me retrouver
je vous en ai souvent parlé dont il a si
ces séjours présente bien celle ci vient
cruel maintenant d'accord quand les
sauver la cie faune et où il a suivi un
entraînement intensif dans un camp du
coeur scheer attendait il veut nous
montrer quelque chose
les parisiens mauvais mais pas perdre et
frisés nous sommes faits comme des rats
à ses 12 qui trouve à dire ton kléber et
qui n'a subi qu'un entraînement
militaire
laissez moi faire geruge quelqu'un que
tu apprécies chier tu es blessé
je tapais les messieurs wawa et tu es
tout seul dans le désert
nous donnons mes amis sur tous derrière
et aux plus jeunes praj parcours s à les
prisonniers schnell jeunesse non non non
non ce qu'ils aiment consommer
[Rires]
je me rends au coupé module de
l'allemand je m'occupe dix mille ha non
pas le cieux pas le sien produits non
non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]